what's going on guys this is rob and for
a long time you guys have been screaming
at me to make a video about toxins so we
were going to cover the in-betweener
today as part of our omega level series
we're actually going to postpone that
for a week so next week we'll do it on
uh on friday but i thought it'd be cool
to make a video explaining uh basically
patrick mulligan slash toxin right i
thought it would be cool because here's
the thing man toxin is op this guy is so
broken okay so toxin first appeared in
uh venom versus carnage vol 1 in 2004
and he was created by peter milligan now
the whole idea behind this and in truth
it was kind of an accidental success one
of the things to know when it comes to
the idea of symbiotes is that they're
usually a product of their time that at
the time that venom was created in
marvel comics it was actually the idea
of jim shooter and all those guys at
marvel to basically change the way
spider-man looked and that's why they
gave him a black suit i wouldn't say the
change was reviled but i will say that
there were enough people out there that
didn't want to see the iconic blue and
red suit go away that marvel changed it
up and so over a period of time using a
combination of circumstances that both
took place inside spider-man's comics as
well as uh really on the publishing side
peter got rid of the venom symbiote and
then it bonded itself to eddie brock and
eddie brock basically became venom now
following that you go into carnage and
the introduction of carnage was a
product of its time in so far as by the
late 80s and early 90s marvel had kind
of taken a page out of dc right the dark
knight returns batman comics made
stories darker which again really
started back in 1971 with the night when
stacey died and so by the time that
carnage hit marvel comics and even comic
books as a whole were like super high
octane fast-paced hyper violent and so
the creation of the carnage symbiote was
designed to reflect that environment and
was hugely successful right maximum
carnage was a wildly successful story
even to this day and so what ended up
happening here is that in 2004 because
marvel was experiencing this sort of
shift at the hands of joe casada the
idea wasn't necessarily to get rid of
venom and carnage but to introduce yet
another symbiote building on top of the
life foundation symbiotes and those we
had seen before but to do it in a way
that was starkly different and so the
way this played out is that in the venom
and carnage storyline really in the
first issue the two of them and the
story itself just kind of opened up with
these guys fighting basically chasing
after a guy named named patrick mulligan
and so what was kind of crazy about this
is that you didn't exactly know what was
happening and in fact it wasn't really
until spider-man showed up on the scene
that you started to learn what was
actually going on now in truth
spider-man's involvement here was
basically just limited to the fact that
like it's venom right and at the time
eddie brock was still effectively a
villain in marvel comics and so whenever
he was roaming around doing something
even if spider-man didn't directly
intervene he was always kind of keeping
an eye on him right i mean it was really
kind of how that played out and so
because of the fact that venom had
showed up at the apartment of a cop and
seemingly looked like he was attacking
the cop that in truth venom was looking
to save patrick mulligan basically from
carnage and what you ended up learning
is the fact that carnage had basically
given birth to an offspring of his own
in the form of toxin and that the way it
was explained by venom is that every
thousandth generation that the symbiotes
potentially have the ability to go crazy
right to become so psychotic that they
could actually lead to the entire
destruction of their race and so where
carnage wanted to destroy the toxin
symbiote because carnage believed it was
a threat to his own existence venom
actually wanted to raise toxin in order
to turn him into what was basically a
productive member of society and so the
idea is that because the symbiote had
bonded itself to a cop it seemed more or
less taken care of but there was no
definitive way for venom to know hence
the reason why he was involved in the
first place now spider-man didn't
initially know this he just thought
venom was attacking a cop
so this basically led to spider-man
stepping in and venom of course kind of
a bit of a conflict between him and
spider-man and so on and then carnage
finally appeared and then tried to kill
mulligan now what followed in issues two
through really three if we're being
honest with ourselves even going into
issues four was basically just a cat and
mouse game it was quite literally venom
fighting carnage carnage fighting venom
spider-man trying to keep up and then
fighting both you know interchangeably
and then ultimately it all kind of
coalesced into issue number four now
during this time felicia hardy who most
of you guys know as black cat uh was
really just kind of a person who was
thrown into the conflict just because
she was basically in the middle of an
art heist when it all started going down
and it actually saved mulligan at some
point and then once mulligan's powers
were developing and then he ultimately
ended up tracking down felicia hardy
that he was basically asking her what's
going on because he didn't fully
understand what was happening to him
with regards to the symbiote that it
possessed his body and so the reason why
felicia hardy was so important is
because by the time you got to issue
number four venom was actually getting
ready to kill carnage but the response
of felicia hardy is the one who really
saved the day was basically saying that
if venom is the father of carnage and
carnage is a father of toxin and these
symbiotes basically have the abilities
once they reach to their their
thousandth generation to basically lose
their mind then they should really just
become like a father and son dynamic to
save toxin right to basically
rehabilitate toxin now ultimately
carnage didn't want to he still wanted
to kill him and it all really fell on
venom but during this whole time the
major play when it came to toxin himself
was the fact that mulligan's wife had
actually given birth to his son and the
biggest issue that mulligan struggled
with here was that given the nature of
the symbiotes themselves the fact that
he didn't fully understand what was
going on with him the fact that he
actually almost turned his baby into a
symbiote to a degree had really led to
this huge crisis in the fact that he was
more of a danger to his family than
anything else and so without really
giving any meaningful explanation to his
wife he basically bailed out and then
took off and so the story ultimately
ended with toxin just kind of walking
out there on his own and this is where
the accidental success comes into play
because it's one of these things where
the story ended in such a way to where
it could have just been left that way
and if it wasn't well received nobody
would care the story would just wrap up
and he would just kind of be out there
in the world nobody would know or care
what happened to him such as it was
people loved it
[Laughter]
people loved the idea of toxin right
they were like wait a minute a new
symbiote that's more powerful than
carnage and venom like yeah man people
plus people love the way toxin looked
right just the kind of combination of
the carnage and venom colors right
people just love the design and
everything truth to tell it was just the
right kind of symbiote story at the
right time and so following this marvel
i wouldn't go as far as to say when all
out but they certainly capitalized on it
and so the following year in 2005 peter
milligan returned again and basically
wrote the toxin six issue mini-series
now the reality of this is that this
mini series ran in tandem with the new
avengers comic and the only reason why
this is really significant is because
when the new avengers comic line was
being launched by marvel right following
the aftermath of avengers disassembled
the traditional avengers roster
disbanding and a new one being formed in
his place you had a story that kicked
off called the raft and the wrath was a
really really cool story of course the
raft being the prison where basically
super villains are held at least those
that are seen seem to be the most
dangerous and seemingly the most
powerful right but regardless of the
situation what it did is that during
this story electro who had actually been
contacted by elektra of course neither
of them related to each other who was
actually a scroll imposter kind of a
precursor to the events of secret
invasion that electro had taken down
power to the raft and when that happened
a ton of criminals escaped now the
reality is peter milligan writing this
comic and marvel commissioning this
comic came hot off the heels of the one
question that seemingly every fan had
after the original venom vs carnage
story which is what can toxin do and so
that's basically what this comic gave us
now it also gave us the nature of toxin
in relation to patrick mulligan as well
as how it is the toxin symbiote compared
to like venom and carnage regarding its
own personality drive and ambitions and
so what you got was again really peter
milligan just kind of nailing it right
in the sense that like this this toxin
series which is still considered to be
one of the best symbiote stories that
has been written in a long long time
focused in one part on the powers of
toxin and in another part on the nature
of toxin now the powers of toxin were
given to us in pretty cool displays in
the sense that when it comes to like his
physical form for the most part he
usually looks comparable to spider-man
in size right he's not really as beefy
or as huge as uh as venom is and he's
not really as scrawny and small as
carnage is but instead he's kind of
somewhere in between but he can kind of
go either way like usually whenever he
gets pissed off he just like doubles in
size right he just becomes enormous and
so you saw him facing off against
characters that weren't really big time
and in fact the idea of toxin tracking
down these different villains like cobra
the answer wrecker piledriver razorfist
had all actually been tasked to him by
spider-man so in a lot of ways it was
really spider-man saying okay so if
you're bonded to patrick mulligan and
you want to be a good guy then let's see
if you can be a good guy right and so a
lot of it was kind of babysitting to a
degree where ultimately toxin was kind
of given a series of tasks to see if he
could complete them in a non-lethal
fashion and as a bigger test of that can
patrick keep his symbiote under control
even more so than that it was really
kind of spider-man observing not really
directly but kind of behind the scenes
kind of coming to this conclusion what's
the toxin symbiote really about and so
as far as the relationship between toxin
and patrick mulligan went it was one of
these things where toxin was very much a
child in terms of how it functioned
right even in terms of its speech it
almost came off childlike and as a
result of this it was in a lot of ways
patrick mulligan taking a child to race
that he had to teach toxin the the
nuances and the complexities of morality
right that just because something is the
right thing to do doesn't necessarily
mean you should do it right because even
though it is the right thing to do it
could cause further suffering later on
down the line and so this kind of of you
know weird moral compass being taught to
toxin was a little difficult in terms of
patrick's endeavors but was highly
intriguing for us as the reader because
we got to see the character revolve in a
way that you didn't normally get to see
in relation to venom and carnage
especially because of the fact that when
venom had bonded to eddie brock and
carnage had bonded to cletus cassidy
they were basically perfect matches the
idea here was that eddie brock had a
hatred for for peter parker because he
cost eddie his job and venom had a
hatred for spider-man because spider-man
cast him off and because spider-man and
peter are the same person eddie bonding
to venom was a perfect match at the same
time the carnage symbiote basically felt
a kind of a sense of abandonment and
being cast aside by venom and then
binding itself to cletus cassidy was
allowed to just experience this
unbridled chaos and carnage seemingly
everywhere it went but where cletus
cassidy and eddie brock embraced their
symbiotes patrick mulligan actually
tried to control his symbiote right
trying to basically bring it under his
wing and really sort of grow and evolve
the symbiote based on his own moral
compass and so in between these
instances when toxin would track down
these various villains that were
attached to him by spider-man what you
would see were these small little
moments where you would see the kind of
relationship between him and patrick in
the same way that you might like placate
a child by giving them a toy one of the
things that patrick had done was
actually strike a kind of deal with
toxin and the deal was that if toxin
would carry out these tasks according to
the will or the the desire of patrick
basically doing it uh with non-lethal
force the toxin would get quote unquote
play time is really how it was referred
to in the sense that for two hours every
day toxin would be the one running the
show and much like you would expect
toxin loved it
it was very childlike in terms of how he
reacted to it it was like yay right and
so one of the things that you saw was
that toxin really reacted to a lot of
things the way that a child would right
in terms of a child growing into
adolescence becoming a teenager things
like that when he read through the
laptop of patrick mulligan and realized
that patrick had basically disdained the
idea of being attached to toxin he
didn't really like toxin he found toxin
to be childlike and he found the process
of having to teach toxin morality to be
hugely overwhelming in effect he wasn't
really ready for fatherhood in that
capacity the toxin got angry and
destroyed the laptop now of course this
led to toxin trying to steal more
spider-man caught him and then yelled at
patrick for basically allowing toxin to
run amok in the in the way that he had
kind of illustrating this idea and
really explaining to him that when it
comes to these symbiotes that as the
host they're the one that's supposed to
be in control that he's supposed to be
like a father here that you wouldn't
just let your child run amok for two
hours especially when they're in such
such a young state right young
adolescents somewhere where toxin really
had the mindset of around like anywhere
between a five to a ten-year-old that
you wouldn't just let them go do their
own thing that they have to be guided
they have to be controlled you've got to
provide boundaries right a kind of uh
system for them to work within and
toxins basically desire to break away
from that is the way it normally works
with kids right testing boundaries
trying to break rules to see what will
happen to see how far they can stretch
things it just goes with the territory
of being a dad the other part of this
that you saw that was really really
intriguing was that toxin really shared
or really seemed to have this this sort
of lack of of confidence in itself that
when it came to beings like venom when
it came to symbiotes like carnage that
for the most part they had historically
bonded themselves to other people and
usually their desire to bond to somebody
was based on a previously existing
emotion like revenge or or rage or
whatever the case happened to be but
because patrick was the first being that
toxin had ever bonded itself to toxin
didn't actually believe it could survive
being bonded to anybody else and much
like a kind of relationship capacity
it's i can't live without you right and
so what this did is it led to a really
interesting dynamic between the two
where it was almost kind of like they
need each other in some form or fashion
that toxin can help patrick really
achieve levels of herod that he simply
wasn't able to do on his own and toxin
needed patrick in order to basically
become a good guy to understand that he
couldn't just tear through things he
couldn't destroy things he couldn't be
hyper violent in the same way that
carnage was and so where the conclusion
of the toxin series basically saw
patrick mulligan and toxin kind of
coming to terms with each other and in
fact patrick actually returning back
home to his family and officially
introducing them to toxin the reality is
that for about seven years really six
years for being honest toxin had
vanished and we didn't really know what
was going on truth to tell if i'm a
betting man i would say that the entire
idea of toxin was seemingly designed to
be self-contained in truth there was a
lot going on with marvel and the reason
why i say this is because it wasn't
until 2011 that toxin came back because
of rick remender and his run on venom
and the funny thing about this is that
this is basically agent venom right now
those guys who don't know who that is
agent venom is basically when flash
thompson became venom and as we've
mentioned multiple times here on the
channel the agent venom run is one of
the most popular runs of the venom
character right people love agent venom
and rightfully so it was exceedingly
well written especially given the
previous struggles that flash thompson
dealt with and the fact that he was the
bully to peter parker as spider-man and
or really before he was spider-man and
so on uh but also the struggles that
flash thompson dealt with before going
into becoming agent venom and then while
and after he was agent venom especially
when he died
that's certainly a pretty major struggle
but the idea here under rick remender is
that toxin i wouldn't quite call him a
plot device but he kind of was the idea
of him being on the same level as he was
during his original appearances by peter
milligan basically seemed to be gone and
if we're being honest it's kind of been
that way for a while and so the way this
played out is that you initially had a
villain by the name of black heart and
black heart is basically one of those
hell lords that exists out there i mean
i guess the idea of of calling him a
hell lord is a little premature he is
more the son of mephisto destined to
become a hill lord but he was ultimately
banished from hell and the desire of
black heart was to actually bring hell
on earth and one of the things he needed
for this was basically the toxin
symbiote or at least a piece of the
toxin symbiote and so as much as old
school toxin fans when i say old school
i mean fan people who were fans of
toxins six years before as much as they
hated it what rick remender had
basically revealed here is that black
had killed patrick mulligan off panel
and had gotten his hands on the toxin
symbiote and so the way this had worked
is that the toxin symbiote basically had
to be freed from this this container
that was being held by blackheart which
of course this was done by flash
thompson uh agent venom at the behest of
crime master and so where agent venom
ended up confronting like jack o'lantern
and all these different characters and
so on and so forth basically uh the
toxin symbiote was taken by jack
o'lantern directly to crime master under
the belief that once flash thompson
realized what was going on that he
wouldn't fulfill the mission as it was
tasked to him but it was necessary that
he be the one to do it because the venom
symbiote was seemingly the only one that
could punch through all the defenses
that were there and then attain the the
toxin symbiote for itself i mean in all
honesty when that happened like when
when you saw that whole scenario take
place the venom symbiote didn't want to
save the toxins simeon he wanted to kill
it he was literally like we have to kill
it right like that was the whole thing
and so what this did where this initial
story took place in in venom volume 2
issues 11 and 12. what you did is you
jumped forward from issue 17 to 21 and
you dealt with this idea that crime
master's desire was to create a group
called the savage six which was really
kind of his own interpretation of the
sinister six to a degree and that what
ended up happening here is eddie brock
was basically kidnapped and then
essentially was forcefully bonded to the
toxin symbiote and so what this did is
at the end of this whole story it
actually led to a conflict between eddie
brock as toxin and agent venom and what
ended up happening here is because toxin
who was really in control of eddie at
the time had basically sided with the
savage six this led to flash thompson
stripping the toxin symbiote off of
eddie brock and then throwing it in the
fire and when the idea was that eddie
was going to be saved instead what
happened is the simeon actually reached
out grabbed eddie and then drug him into
the fire and then seemingly eddie brock
died as well now in reality because of
how this was done and because of how
marvel had been functioning really from
the the time that toxin was first
introduced running all the way up into
the the end of like dark rain the idea
of the heroic age so kind of like the
conclusion of this 10-year effort by joe
casada to basically reshuffle marvel by
all standards of measurement eddie was
done right it was basically the end of
eddie brock there was no need for him
anymore now in truth the death of eddie
as it was handled at the time was done
fairly unceremoniously right like quite
literally eddie brock gets pulled into
the flames and then flash thompson's
like well i mean there's nothing i can
do my symbiote won't survive it so only
one thing to do now we gotta go save
betty brandt right and that was it right
i mean it wasn't like some great big
huge grandiose thing it wasn't like a
funeral for eddie brock or anything like
that he was basically just removed from
the picture and the mantle of venom
seemingly belonged strictly to flash
thompson and it looked like he would be
the only venom going forward now the
funny thing about this is that if you go
back and you read the letters pages in
the aftermath of venom 21 fans were
pissed right fans of eddie brock were
mad they were so angry because they felt
like what had been a long-standing
member of the marvel mythos especially
regarding the symbiotes was just kind of
whimsically cast aside to make way for
flash thompson this ironically coincided
with rick remender's run concluding on
agent venom and so beginning with the
monsters of evil you had cullen bunn who
took over now toxin didn't immediately
come back when colin bunn took over the
writing of venom instead that didn't
really happen until a little bit later
and what you actually ended up finding
out in issue number 34 was that both
eddie brock and toxin had survived but
both of them were imbued with huge
amounts of rage that eddie brock wanted
his venom symbiote back and toxin wanted
to kill venom for killing him in the
first place we're trying to kill him in
the first place and so the result of
this is that the two of them bonded to
each other but they weren't really a
suitable match right they were a match
by circumstance but they weren't really
a perfect match in the same way that
eddie brock was a match for venom or
cletus cassidy was a match for carnage
now some of this also had to do with the
the really individual motivations of the
more so eddie brock than toxin himself
that toxin sure wanted to kill venom and
that's really not the biggest thing in
the world but eddie's desire was to bond
back with the venom symbiote and so i
mean sure toxin wanted to kill venom and
really not necessarily venom i feel like
that's an incorrect statement toxin
wanted to kill flash thompson eddie
brock wanted to take the venom symbiote
back and so because the desire of eddie
was was not really to truly bond with
toxin their bond was for the most part
incomplete it didn't really have a
massive impact on the powers that they
had but it did impact really the future
of the characters and the fact that we
as the reader knew they didn't it seemed
like they weren't really gonna stay a
cohesive unit now this belief was
totally turned on its head in literally
the next issue
in issue number 35 and the reason why is
because one eddie brock and flash
thompson had to team up to basically
save the school but two there was this
speech that was made by flash thompson
to eddie brock in relation to how they
see the world and how they do things it
was one of the most significant moments
because this is really the thing that
kind of changed eddie brock for those of
you guys who are curious how it is that
eddie went from like the guy who was
like venom and he was the villain and he
did some bad stuff to the guy that kind
of became eddie brock as we know him
today this is kind of what started it
and the idea is that eddie brock
approaches flash thompson from the
perspective of saying the venoms can't
be controlled right the venoms can't be
contained they have a mind of their own
and different things like that but the
response to flash thompson is no you say
that because you're a coward the reality
is that the symbiotes can be controlled
i know that because i'm controlling mine
and the reason why i'm controlling mine
is because i'm trying to build a life
i'm trying to make up for my past sins
i'm trying to atone for the things that
i've done wrong in my life by trying to
do some measure of right given this
power that i've had you eddie brock are
a slave to your past you're a slave to
the mistakes that you've made you live
by them you let them define you you let
them control you and because you feel
like you cannot control your life right
in the passenger seat of your own life
everything that comes your way you
simply just let it happen and so this
toxin symbiote the venom symbiote these
different symbiotes that have possessed
you over the years they basically they
basically engage in their own will it
happened to be that you and venom had
the same motivations but the reality of
you and how you see the world and the
reality of what makes you who you are
came to bear with toxin when that
symbiote bonded to you and there was
nothing you could do to control it it's
not that you can't it's you don't
believe you can because quite literally
eddie brock you have nothing worth
living for and so while that was really
like just a hard thing to hear right and
in a lot of ways it seemed to kind of
crush eddie brock the truth was that
flash thompson was right and so what it
did is it actually unified eddie brock
and toxin in a way that hadn't really
been done before in the sense that now
they were seemingly a cohesive unit
again the big issue you had here though
is that venom and eddie brock they were
just synonymous anybody who had been a
spider-man fan for any measure of time
had just absolutely felt that eddie
brock and venom had to go together it
was one of these things where you simply
just couldn't separate them now if we're
also being honest whether it had been
cullen bunn or anybody else it all
basically would have gone back to normal
but in order to keep the toxin symbiote
under control there was a kind of uh i
guess a drug based cocktail that was
used that the toxin symbiote would only
ever really come out when it needed to
now all this really basically ended when
you went into jerry conway's carnage run
which i really enjoyed that's the
carnage run where you deal with like
carnage the dark hole cathode all that
kind of stuff and so what you had here
was a younger woman uh by the name of uh
jubilee i think it's how you pronounce
her name i'm not going to swear by it i
probably screwed it up but jubilee von
scotter
the important thing here is that she had
received what was basically a dark hole
modified version of the carnage symbiote
that had kind of been bonded to it right
to allow her to operate is basically a
kind of agent of carnage to a degree but
the way this played out is that because
the power of carnage with catholic was
so astronomical that eddie brock
actually gave his toxin symbiote to
jubilee so she could destroy carnage by
merging it with her symbiote as well as
the raised symbiote now what ended up
happening is that with this defeat also
came what was seemingly the destruction
of all the symbiotes and jubilee herself
right that cathode was finally defeated
given the fact that if he was able to
emerge he would basically bring hell on
earth so it was literally everybody
trying to stop catholic
which succeeded but in the process the
toxin symbiote was destroyed now the big
concern here that a lot of people had is
what's ever going to happen to the toxin
symbiote when i say the big concern i
really mean only those who were reading
it at the time because by way of what
had happened between rick remembers run
and cullen buns run while what happened
with toxin was kind of cool the writing
was on the wall you knew it was only a
matter of time before toxin was just
written out of the marvel mythos and
nothing was ever going to come of him
again which was really kind of
disappointing because he was one of
these characters who just never really
had a chance to shine in any real real
impactful and important way and so all
this came to a head during donnie case's
run with the king and black story and as
most of you guys know the king and black
story basically dealt with the arrival
of null the symbiote god showing up on
earth and basically conquering the
entirety of the universe and then
spreading in an outward direction during
this time toxin along with the other
symbiotes really the uh the life
foundation symbiotes had essentially
re-emerged but for toxin himself he
actually ended up bonding himself to a
kid named bren waters and of course we
talked about this during our extreme
carnage video from yesterday so you're
welcome to get caught up on it if you
want to a lot of this went directly into
extreme carnage itself in the sense that
toxin basically fought alongside flash
thompson who had been returned following
his death and it basically become agent
anti-venom so he wasn't really agent
venom anymore that title had now gone
back to eddie brock and that in turn
working alongside these guys basically
toxin was able to help uh you know flash
thompson and and a few other members of
the team basically end up defeating
carnage you know at his attempt at a
return and that was basically it right
but for the most part toxin is one of
these characters and i feel like we've
said this so much in recent years toxins
one of these characters that marvel
introduced never gave any real
measurement of time to and then killed
him off but i really think toxins one of
these characters that can really shine
in marvel comics right he is very very
very very cool but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end uh
thank you guys for watching if you guys
are interested in seeing any of the
stories that we talked about here we
might do
venom versus carnage and and just do
like the actual origin of toxin but if
you guys are are interested in any of
that let me know down in the comment
section and i will catch you all later
peace